hey folks welcome to another scp
explained community questions episode
today we're answering all your burning
concerns about the multiverse's most
monstrous monarch the scarlet king you
may remember the episode where scp-343
was kind enough to come chat with us
directly about his queries but
thankfully the scarlet king hasn't been
quite so hands-on wrong
it
howling
is
the crimson khan
the scarlet king himself before i tear
down the walls of your universe and
destroy every last one of you i will
first take the time to address your
idiotic questions so that your hope may
be thoroughly crushed before i crush
your world to match
the small-minded pandora said question
even though you have taken out literally
gods from your universe and you ruled
some of them how do you feel to know
that you have new gods to pray and
possibly worry about in the scp
foundation
[Laughter]
do you think your worthless gods hold
any surprises for me i was slaughtering
gods by the millions before your
universe's inception
by the time your worthless forebearers
were slithering from the primordial soup
i have conquered and subjugated greater
pantheons of outer gods than your minds
can even conceive
the scarlet king
worries about nothing
the worthless ricardo anguiano said
question what do you think about the
other anomalous goi such as the
serpent's hand or the chaos insurgency
what does the book think of ants it's
crushing those pathetic bookworms are
acolytes of knowledge that will become
meaningless under my food i will
incinerate the library and toast
skewered serpents on its heat and the
so-called chaos insurgency
don't make me laugh they wouldn't know
true chaos if it tore their world
asunder beneath them the feeble team
blaster said ah yes mr king is it
scarlet king to you
i have but a simple question what other
scps do you enjoy
and if you had to name another scp as a
close friend who or what would that be
enjoy
the only things i enjoy our pain
suffering subjugation and desolation i
suppose the ones i despise the least
comparatively are those that seek to
further my own goals of returning the
universe back to its true state of
primal violence i'll destroy them last
the quivering jet ender said i would
keep it simple but useful can 682 be
destroyed permanently not necessarily
any information about how
just getting the answer directly from
682 supposed father of whether it's even
worth the trouble to keep trying to
terminate that dang lizard the only
thing that can destroy anything and
everything is me no exceptions
but i wouldn't destroy a talent
until he has outlived his usefulness
everything will end
but it will only end when i see fit
speaking of which
the inadequate eres skyla said question
if you hate all of existence so much why
not get rid of your children
like they're technically part of
existence so how come you hate existence
but make existence your children i don't
like repeating myself human as i said
before
everything has its time for the time
being my daughters are still of use to
me i will not destroy them until they
have played their part in my crimson
crusade next question the unspeakably
weak ross albatross said i present them
with a query have you ever considered
wearing something other than red with
the dark colored horns on top you're
definitely more of a winter than a
summer also if your skin is inflamed
with rosacea i have a really good serum
for that next thing you know the scarlet
king changes his name to gold king and
forces everyone in the world to wear
only complimentary colors that fit their
own complexion and hair color my armor
will be another color than red when
[Music]
seems to have stuck the moronic xavier
valencia said question when did this
hatred for existence begin
like did something happen to you or have
you always had it my hatred for
existence began when i began to exist
what a signature of this is
we only live to die
regardless of the blink of existence in
between i'm merely hurrying a natural
process along to its logical conclusion
the blithering mr underscore muffin said
i would just ask him how his day's been
if he's going through something and
needs someone to lighten his mood you
know
the usual killing you and your entire
family horribly would lighten my mood
muffin man any pathetic attempts to
console me will only increase my rage
the insulin adam artifact said i have a
question how come you couldn't get to
earth when you destroyed powerful gods
and big planets without even having to
use your full power
you dare question my power artha being
shut out of your worthless dimension is
only a temporary affliction
before you know it the walls that will
keep you safe will crack and crumble the
last thing you will ever see is my dread
army spotting out the sky ready to tear
every last one of you to shreds
then you will know my true power
a buffoon known as the sauce who names
themselves the sauce
said
i would simply ask him the question
everyone has on their mind how much wood
would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck
could chuck wood and i await his answer
that was a terrible question and i hate
you when a scarlet sun rises over your
world i will ensure that your death is
especially painful for this
especially given how stupid your name is
an insect named denzel brown said the
first question you usually have to ask a
being like this is in your rampage
across the multiverse have you ever
encountered another version of yourself
or one comparable in terms of power or
presence
if so
what happened can more than one version
of you exist in the same space
there is only one scholarly king i am an
immutable being a fixed point i have
never had an equal in all the desolate
claims of the universe as i've rendered
into atomic fragments
this is my power
this is my unity
i will bring the multiverse together in
the quiet rift of oblivion
next question a worm named rifts said i
would ask him who do you consider the
greatest threat to your goal
there are no threats to my goal
only bumps in the road
there is no threat there is nothing that
will stop me from fulfilling my destiny
i get out of here next question next
question
the misguided archbishop said question
have you ever faced a foe that's given
you a good challenge
if so
how did you manage to beat them
many of the gods i once faced when i was
a weaker being gave me the closest
battles i've had in trillions of years
thankfully after defeating them
i feasted on their flesh
making me even stronger
a weakling named knight fiend said
question do you meet with bright for
poker every tuesday or wednesday cause
let's face it dude has to be one of your
best friends or your worst enemies
you are a fool to think a new human
could ever be on my level with or
without some garish piece of magical
jewelry in his last moments this dr
wright will thank me as i rip that
medallion from his stolen neck and crush
it in my face
a peasant named static production said i
will ask him what does he gain after
destroying the earth is it really his
goal or is he trying to impress someone
i would also ask does he like pineapple
on pizza i will gain peace
silence
blessed emptiness
in the destruction of all things i will
look across a quiet multiverse and bring
a sigh of immense relief and my favorite
pizza topping is fallen warriors
sliced very thin
the mindless wind general said i'd ask
him if he knows anything about other
multiverses aside from the scp
multiverse
like star wars lord of the rings halo hp
lovecraft creepypasta etc if he does
what does he know about them
i have been there and destroyed them all
already
darth vader i felled in a single blow as
he begged for mercy
gandalf i burned until not even ashes
remained
the so-called master chief i cast into
an endless black hole
was torn apart by my minions
i personally killed jeff the killer
you will be
be
next
supreme spider who are we kidding here
only i am truly supreme said i would ask
him if in a hypothetical situation he
managed to reach his goal of
annihilating everything what would he do
after
laugh
next question the platitudinous mezda
song said question
what is existing for you in particular
do you have a body capable of feeling
things like touch or smell are you just
a conscience capable to be manifested or
something so alien that can't be
explained with our language
i am able to exist as a fixed point in
time space while also operating as a
diffuse consciousness across the scope
of the multiverse existing at various
degrees of strength and influence
depending on the operations of my
acolytes
on earth i can only sense feelings and
impressions until the gate is opened and
rest assured it will be opened for me
the machine loving brolio
what a dumb name
said
what are your thoughts on yaldabaoth and
mccain considering they created what one
of the things you hate the most i am
quite curious about your thoughts on
them mere pretenders to the scarlet
throne their petty squabbles of the fate
of something as inconsequential as the
human race is simply embarrassing if
meccan thinks he's the broken god
[Music]
a nerd named dr veronica said if you
were forced to fight king crimson from
jojo's bizarre adventure who would win
in that battle between king crimson
versus crimson king
divallo says that he is the king of
kings after all so the two of you would
seemingly be mortal enemies
this means nothing to me
you should spend less time reading your
picture books and more time preparing
for me to breach your dimension and
destroy all of you
a foolhardy mortal named green said
question how do you feel about being
looked down upon as an ant
i wouldn't know
it's never happened to me how does it
make you feel
inside
a bootlegger named james rogers said i
would ask him if he was hiring since i
know every single scp and everything
about the 05 council i'm sure i could be
of assistance to him
you can assist me in sabotaging the
works of the scp foundation who are
slightly more irritating than your
average humans they have gained an
awareness of me and my plans and thus
they must be eliminated in order to
prevent any barriers to my plans
in exchange for your loyalty
i'll kill you quickly and personally
and you will have the honor of dying at
my hands
the meaningless collection of letters
mttnyn
said
question
what is your favorite beverage to enjoy
after a day of destruction and mayhem
the blood and tears of my enemies of
course
next question the appropriately named
pig master said i'd ask him what's the
deal with airline food
humans survive for an incredibly brief
period of time
every time i blink another several
thousand of you will fizzle out of
existence soon to be forgotten another
faceless soul in the great trend
none of you will live long enough to
have any meaningful impact on your world
other than sucking up resources and
creating a mess
in your final years unless you die young
or violently you will feel your body and
mind starting to fail
little by little your faculties will
leave you you will break down
you will exit this world just as afraid
and feeble and infantile as you entered
it and after it an eternity of nothing
awaits
so you distract yourself from this
immutable and inevitable reality by
instead focusing on details as trivial
as the poor taste of food on airplanes
the godless jason gutman said i would
ask him if he reads high fantasy and
science fiction to get inspiration for
his conquests
no
authors of your feeble fiction get faint
impressions of my dark conquests in the
forms of nightmares they cannot
understand or shake when they awaken
they make these impressions into their
work in hopes of exercising them
so your high fantasy and science fiction
get their inspiration from me
not the other way around
the blabbering olivia kneeler said
dear scarlet king have you ever
considered taking a break from planning
the end of all living beings to try and
engage in some artistic recreational
activities
there's coloring in painting pitching a
play creating sculptures building lego
and creating film media
if you ever consider doing one of these
activities which would you do
olivia you misunderstand me i already
have a number of creative pursuits
i create fear in my countless victims i
assemble armies from the rivals of
sadistic demons and incomprehensible
entities
i create dark schemes for the conquest
of the multiverse each with intricate
and masterful details
and if destruction is also a form of
creation then nobody is more creative
than me
the disgustingly dull april morning said
i've thought long and hard about this
and what i'd like to ask is as follows
what kind of feline companion does one
have
knowing that all cats are basically bent
on world domination it behooves oneself
to align with said company i have no
feline companions and when i enter your
universe i will destroy you and your cat
next question the gormless difference yt
said question
how often do you wash your body i wash
my body in the blood of my enemies every
time i battle which is extremely often
the grossly sentimental girl garcia said
my question would be are you bored
lonely
i can never feel bored when crushing my
enemies seeing them driven before me
hearing the lamentations of their women
and then crushing their women too
being lonely on the other hand is my
intention i despise having to spend time
around any other living beings
and no
i don't want to chat platypus king said
do you like platypuses all you have ever
known
platypus king
the perverse coffee addict said my
learning question would have to be
are you single
winky face
no
i did have a wife once but i crushed her
to death and used her blood to paint my
armor since then i've taken my seven
daughters as my bride
tlc has been in touch about licensing a
reality show but i destroyed every
representative they have sent into my
kingdom
the sniveling emerald inferno zero said
i would ask him if there was a
possibility to turn me into basically a
less powerful but still pretty powerful
version of him i can turn you into a
steamy pile of ash
that's my best offer crimson gorgotter
i quite like that name said i would ask
him why he thinks destroying the
multiverse would stop the pain he has
suffered because if he does he will be
completely and truly alone forever
suffering the isolation for all of
eternity and that is exactly how i like
it when i've destroyed everything else
in destroying myself
the universe will then finally be silent
but worry now there will be plenty of
time for violence howling and bloody
conquests before them
the hopelessly naive mass tv said has he
ever considered becoming a superhero put
on a cape or cowl save people from a few
natural disasters and get the love and
admiration of an entire world i have no
interest in saving people i don't want
their love and admiration i want their
fear
their screams
their blood
no hero will save them the defeatist
vixen lady said i tell him that
destroying all human life is the right
thing to do
i'm glad to hear you approve of my
mission as a treat i'll destroy you
first when i get into your dimension
the scarlet sayer said i'd ask him what
are your thoughts on anime waifus do
demonic beings appeal to you or are we
nothing more than gross gnats trying to
present ourselves as we were one like
you
you should feel deeply embarrassed for
even asking this scarlet sayer also
change your name if you infringe on me
anymore you'll hear from my bloodthirsty
interdimensional lawyers
and if you think i'm cruel
you have no idea what they'll do to you
lonelyguy said have you ever considered
anger management classes i did join an
anger management group once
but i had them all liquidated for being
insolent in the end
the truly infuriating johnny the gamer
said
my question is simple why destroy
existence and conquer gods when you
could just binge every conceivable tv
show or anime ever
seeing how you're immortal and such you
certainly have the time
because having an eternal life is still
having a life johnny and i have better
things to do than waste my time on
bingeing your worthless television shows
and mma
when i eventually destroy you it will be
a mercy i am looking forward to the last
season
foxy tv say
everybody asks who's the scarlet king
what's the scarlet king
i wanna know
how is the scarlet king he is furious
after answering all of these moronic
questions
my existence is eternal and this still
feels like a profound waste of my time
everyone who took part in this i hope
you know
you are on my list
and when my terrible armies reach this
dimension
rest assured
they'll be coming after you
first
well then now go check out children of
scp-001 the scarlet king is
scp-999 really his son and
scp-001 how actually powerful is the
scarlet king for more of the literal
worst guy in the multiverse